pensemos en algo a que creen que sea
igual 17 entre 2 pueden darse cuenta de
inmediato de que no es obvio que tengo
que multiplicar a 2 para que sea igual a
17 aquí no hay un número entero que
podamos poner para que al multiplicarlo
por 2 sea 17
sabemos que 2 por 8 es un poco menor a
17 pues 2 por 8 es igual a 16 y sabemos
que 2 por 9 es un poco mayor a 17 es
igual a 18 por lo que esta interrogación
dos por interrogación es igual a 17 esto
nos ayuda a saber a que es igual
este valor desconocido porque va a estar
entre 8 y 9 va a ser igual a 8 punto
algo hagamos otro ejemplo si alguien les
dice vamos a pensar a que es igual 18
entre 4 no tenemos que saber a que es
igual esto aún pero quiero que piensen
entre qué par de números enteros
consecutivos se encuentra el resultado
de 18 entre 4 podemos hacer algo similar
veamos 4 x 4 es igual a 16
un poco menor a 18 y podemos decir que 4
por 5 es igual a 20 que es un poco mayor
a 18 por lo que 4 x interrogación es
igual a 18 esto nos ayuda a darnos
cuenta de que como 18 está entre 16 y 20
esta interrogación se encuentra entre 4
y 5 por lo que 18 entre 4 va a ser 4
punto algo otra forma de estimar a que
se acercará una división es mediante una
desigualdad si dijéramos 87 entre 9 como
lo compraríamos con 10 hay un par de
formas de comparar esto quizá esto sea
mayor a 10 o quizás sea igual a 10 o
quizás sea menor a 10 pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolver lo que pondrían
aquí mayor o igual a o menor a 10
sabemos que no es igual a 10 sabemos que
90 entre 9 es igual a 10 y si vemos un
múltiplo de 9 menor a esto sabemos que
81 entre 9 es igual a 9 por lo que 87
entre 9 va a estar entre estos dos
valores
usemos otro color
87 / 9 va a hacer algo entre 9 y 10 por
lo que va a ser menor a 10 el objetivo
de este vídeo es comenzar a
familiarizarnos con esta idea de dividir
en donde podemos tener un resultado que
no sea un número entero más adelante
veremos cómo calcular esto pero por
ahora vamos a aprender a estimar lo para
darnos una idea de que este cálculo va a
estar entre 8 y 9 este va a estar entre
4 y 5 y este va a estar entre 9 y 10 lo
que significa que es menor a 10